brilliantly I don't know whose idea it
was
but the idea to have you be a therapist
and to put you in a role where you sat
and you listened to people so you we
could look at your face and we can take
you could take advantage of that amazing
timing that we talked about earlier such
a brilliant idea but I'm curious did dr.
Bob Hartley ever help anybody
when you watch that show that you laughs
you're laughing and you don't get the
sense that you there's never any kind of
diagnosis you're always saying well
we're out of time and then
well I they should have pulled my you
know my my license after three years
because I never helped anybody but in
real life I acted in it was very nice I
was in some town I was doing my stand-up
and I got a note from a woman and she
said she and her husband and and their
son were having problems and she what
she went to the boy and said to him you
know as you know we're having problems
and we want to be a happy loving family
would you mind going to a therapist and
and he said well as he is the therapist
like that man on television and she said
yes he said okay y'all go you were
clearly terrible at what you did yeah
it's a kid what do they know
you